Friday magazine did a big feature on
CNN's chief White House correspondent
Jim Acosta along with other colleagues
in it Acosta says Americans are too
clueless to see that trump's feisty bond
with the press is fake and that trumps
act will only encourage violence on
people like Jim hence these solemn
pictures which make Jim look like hunted
prey they seem to say Here I am
out here risking my life for you to
battle the Great Satan Trump here's what
he said people around the country don't
know it's an actor they're not you know
in the act and they take what he says
seriously and they take attacks from
Sean Spicer and Sarah Sanders and and
what they do to us on a daily basis very
seriously they don't have all their
faculties in some cases they're their
elevator might not hit all floors my
concern is is that there's a better
journalist is going to be hurt one of
these days faculties so Trump might
trigger crazy Americans to go after him
or Jim or others fair enough
Jim feels a little like projection he
seemed kind of angry yourself could you
be a hazard to the American public I
wouldn't cut you off in traffic anyway
while it's true unstable people do exist
Jim misses the point that we all get
Trump creates chaos and friction from
which to negotiate he knows that he's
outgunned by the media they have all the
ink plus there's the bias that drips
with disdainful superiority what Jeff
Jim reflects daily so this act is
something everyone wishes they could do
to correct the imbalance but ultimately
Trump treats the media the same way he
treats North Korea Iran even Republicans
so Jimmy or no special case he's doing
it to everyone you just have to have the
faculties to see it and you have to be
calm and professional enough to deal
with it but maybe your elevator can't
reach a floor where that's possible so
we ran that tape to show you that we
weren't taking his words out of context
and we're gonna even respond we're gonna
I'm gonna read his response on Twitter
this is Jim Acosta or che Acosta who as
I like to call regarding my interview
with variety my comments have been
twisted by some outlets as you can
plainly see I'm not referring to Trump
supporters I'm talking about people who
threaten journalists links to transcript
and vid
Oh below interesting Kimberley thoughts
on this quite a dance move a little bit
of the Macarena with the electric slide
tone and a little bit of moonwalking
because he's like I better push this
back yeah because people are like what
because you don't want to do what
Hillary Clinton did and people then take
it the wrong you know you have to speak
your opinion but then if you start to
insult voters or clinging to guns and
religion or you're saying that you know
this is you know the men and women of
America can't make up their own minds
people don't like to be told they can't
have their opinion write their thoughts
and for you to question their motivation
or their intelligence or their
understanding of the situation now that
being said I mean I like the way that
was shot it was nice from a production
standpoint it was almost like okay what
is this the news and the bold and the
beautiful whatever I don't know yeah
it's kind of dreamy or cept I don't know
what it was dreamscape I enjoyed our
promo so what I actually do I get the
point about external threats by unstable
weirdos we all face that you know but
you know he's not in Vietnam I mean this
is he's in the White House press corps
this is his job and of course what we do
when we do the five we get crazy people
- yes only one or two but I'm listening
to you there probe MSNBC but if you if
you're saying that and imagine that you
know your Jim Acosta and you are CNN and
you're the ones that are being pile
driven by the president and his Twitter
feed and all that and you're asking
really tough the other day he asked the
question about daca at the Easter Egg
Roll and he said everybody went on the
right wing crazy or April Ryan saying
that she now has police law enforcement
on speed dial she gets threats for
asking the other day she asked Sarah
Huckabee Sanders if Trump was thinking
about quitting and that set up so
everybody have that unspeakable so if
you if you're having that experience
can't you understand why Jim Acosta
might say they're people who are
unhinged well I think that that's what
he tried to say I think I was saying
before no I think that's what he said
you're saying where everybody stupid
that they won't get they don't get the
act well I would say that the guy that
shot up a congressional Republican
police game I mean was he inflamed by
CNN I mean you can't have it both ways
you can't say Oh
Trump's gonna call us fake news if
someone's going to shoot us well okay so
then the guy that shot Scalise that's
your fault Jim I mean I don't like that
whole blame game I mean people are crazy
and your job is soft Jim you sit in the
chair
yes question this is not Vietnam and
this is nothing you're not under siege
everything's fine I know I have it good
I spent a lot of years in the field Greg
just to be fair to Jim we go we'll look
at the transcript we can make up our own
minds but if there was a Fox News White
House correspondent and he was berating
Barack Obama and he was hostile and he
was partisan and he was a little rude
he'd be celebrated by a lot of people in
this country but he would not get
Variety magazine write-ups yeah be
honest no one will ever do that to me
David seem like he's unhappy when he's
there and it's just it's like it might
be a bit of a projection does the White
House Correspondents Dinner the
president's not going is gonna go to a
rally feature of NBC she was on the
campaign trail and she did does write
about when she was in the press pen and
the president was talking about the fake
news media that people that are ginned
up at these rallies would go after them
not physically touch them but they would
have to be escorted out by Secret
Service so that they could be protected
I think perhaps that might have been
what they were referring to and that's
not good yeah I don't know